loulo j'ai des cours tu que des courtes
c'est une femme elle pleure elle est à
la maternité elle pleure elle regarde
son bébé elle est en larmes elle lui dit
quand je pense qu'il ya neuf mois j'ai
fait et avaler
[Rires]
je balance tout à une blague sa droite
oui chameaux et un éléphant se
rencontrent pour la première fois ouais
alors est enfin aider pourquoi tu as de
nichons sur le dos aux chameaux et le
chameau dieppois pourquoi alors c'est un
ancien chauffeur de bus qui prépare une
excursion avec des tétraplégiques
lendemain donc il a préparé son autobus
donc il enlève tous les sièges et aimé
des grosses barres pour attacher les
fauteuils roulants et tout donc il fait
ça toute la nuit et où le lendemain elle
va les chercher ils les monts qui les
attache très très bien et où il a un peu
en panique et tout ça pour agresser les
attaches du bien et où ils y vont et
commence à rouler et on roule doucement
parce qu'il a un peu peur donc il roule
doucement et là est tétraplégique sont
un peu at il envie d avoir un peu de
vitesse donc ils commencent à chanter
chauffeurs cité champions puis appuyez
chauffeurs cité champions appuyé sur le
champignon bien chauffer recommençons
pas chauffé l'accélère un petit peu mais
ça ne suffit pas de plus gros party au
ofer cité champignons puis ça a tout la
chanson chauffer si tu es champion
ap / champignons d'accord il accélère
encore mais ça ne va toujours pas d'eau
qui repart
si tu es champion du chauffeur si les
champions puis sur un champignon là le
chauffeur comment s'énerver il accélère
et l'accélérer l'accélère il rentre dans
un platane il regarde le chauffeur comme
ça tout l'état prédit aux gars de
chauffeurs comme ça il a les jambes
encastré dans le volant il le regarde il
chante il est des noms
[Applaudissements]
elle va vous au caire moi c'est une
histoire de cet instinct coupe de pieds
noirs
oui le mec se lève le matin il va dans
la salle de bain ils constatent que
robinet fuit il va sa femme elle dort
encore il fait ça et 18 mois et dit
pourquoi ce fut encore elle dit [ __ ] et
elle dit fait le idou je suis plombier
il dit je travaille comme une bête
il y appelle le plombier il vient il
répare et dit [ __ ] c'est pas compliqué
et d'ici comme le gazon là il n'est pas
tendu et disait elle dit elle dit mais
fait lui ai dit d'où je suis jardinier
et dit je travaille appelle le jardinet
mme lemay 30 le soir le gazon tondu
nickel il va dans la salle de bal
robinet fuit fais à ma femme
il en a journée qui a fait venir et le
plombier le jardinier devinant maurice à
côté lui les gentils j'ai dit à mon
gazon il est trop il ya ma robinetterie
elle marche pas il a dit d'accord je te
fais tout mais tu me fais une gâterie
ou alors tu me fais un bon gâteau il ya
à l'heure tu dois faire mon gâteau elle
fait 12e suis pâtissier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voici mondiale sabran cocker on a alors
c'est une petite fille s'appelle
maliciels et très maline à la 7 8 ans et
donc elle va voir sa maman le matin il
se lève comme ça et avant que sa maman
partent au travail a lui dit oui j tizi
hier soir à être papa je voudrais y fit
savoir ce que vous faites parce que
c'était sur lui comme ça c'est comme ça
comme ça et j'ai eu très peur je voulais
savoir ce que vous faites
alors ça me va lui dit tu sais malicia
en ce moment ton père a beaucoup grossi
et maman essaye chaque jour 2 2 comme ça
de dieu de faire aplatir ce ventre c'est
qu'il a beaucoup de l'entrée et tous les
soirs tous les soirs je vois là et à lui
fait croire ça sent bien que mal et elle
fait bien maman ça sert à la mer
comprend rien fait pour que tu me dises
ça il va masquer le matin quand une
heure au travail et que ma nounou
reprise mais le soufflé n'est pas pareil
un petit garçon ayant nacelle de bras et
sa mère sort de la douche nu il regarde
le sexe de sa mère et lui dit maman
c'est quoi ça il va mettre un petit peu
je n'ai dit l'egypte à ça c'est le bon
dieu tu sais de bonduelle a créé l'homme
il a créé la femme et puis quand il a
créé la famille la vue qui manque un
détail donc il a été dans sa caisse à
outils il a pris une petite hache et il
a fait une incision et le wat pho non
non non merde en plein dans la chatte et
dont c'est beau et dante un joli c'est
que c'est tout
et j'y arrive pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est un mec qui rentre dans un livre
dans un troquet et je voudrais avoir de
whisky s'il vous plaît le gars lui sert
les deux whiskys lamboing puis bâle 2e
revient le lendemain et souplesse de
whisky ou skier de whisky qui
comprendrait pourquoi ils lui demandent
de whisky au bout de trois quatre
semaines
excusez moi monsieur vous vous êtes tous
les jours ou demander de whisky demander
moins de 1
buvez le est deuxième et vous buvez in
an c'est compliqué j'étais à l'armée
avec un copain on buvait toujours un
whisky à deux lancers c'est pareil on
s'est un peu perdue vue donc voilà pour
une petite pensée voilà je bois de
whisky il
ok d'accord et revient un mois deux mois
trois mois six mois plus tard il rentre
dans le bar crédit en whisky s'il vous
plaît médias
j'ai compris dit non moi j'ai arrêté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
jamais craint d'abord il faut qu'on soit
le patron d'air le baril fait qu'ici
vous prenez du whisky le mec lui c'est
un whisky le type bois luiz qui se bat
patron il fait monsieur il fait oui mais
il faut payer 10 balles pourquoi il dit
parce que vous avez pris 6,10 non
monsieur vous l'avez faire a dit comment
ça vous a offert ce qu'il va dire oui
vous me dis qu'est-ce que vous prenez
moi quand je dis à quelqu'un qui est ce
que vous prenez
c'est que j'invite moi je fais pas gaffe
aux formulations et mais c'est important
monsieur voilà moi j'ai cru que c'était
à faire sinon j'aurais tout autre chose
libre en bas hockey bien le mec s'en va
le lendemain il a rien donc le patron le
voile reconnaît la danse a dit rien le
mec va au bar pour 1,9 casse l'ofs il
nous avait un couteau pas trop lui je
vous ai rien dit il fait la moindre
excuse et un couteau j'ai un couteau
il prend le couteau ils enlèvent
évidemment les locaux qui il commence à
couper l'oeuf en petits carrés mais ici
vous faites là dit je prépare mes zapa
pour la pêche pour la pêche et le baril
il n'empêche à neuf mais il sait que ces
conneries les quarante ans que je pêche
jamais entendu parler de pêche à l'oeuf
a failli passer à côté d'un truc énorme
y voyez le petit bout des flammes le
petit carré vous le mettez au bout de
l'hameçon vous jeter ça un peu loin du
bord et alors la veille avec ça
qu'est-ce que vous prenez et bien risqué
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dingue comment on peut faire rire
sans être sa lingerie patron des trucs
incroyables dans l'église santa que
d'être elles marchent pas bien fait ses
devoirs dans ce journal mais là qu'elle
a marché d'un garçon qui est très pressé
les rebelles sari rouge et elle arrive à
très vite sur la route
et puis quand même la voiture je te jure
c'est la presse avait eu l'impression
qu'ils avaient une ferrari kacou acteurs
devant lui mais qu'il faille se garde
pas et tout est une claque c'est bien le
double attentat les renier dit non tu
sais combien j'ai de chemins non j'ai
500 chevaux mais foncerai petites routes
etc qui se paye ariège est une force de
la marque t'on de la mare et le tracteur
il passa règlement change a raconté
moi en ont fait voir c'est m les chevaux
ont fait boire c b ah là là il m'a dit
c'est un type et rentrer chez lui sa
femme et à palets sur le canapé le mec à
rentrer chez lui il a un canard dans les
bras il te reste le canard et dit à vue
j'ai une grosse truie un pas familier
n'importe quoi c'est pas une truite
c'est un canard fait ta gueule je te
parle pas toi tu fasses pas danser mars
et avait plusieurs fois fait les gens ne
rient pas la chute pourquoi pourquoi
parce que c'est pas un défaut de
recomptage
parce que là les moyens c'est le mot
choisi les bêtes peut-être peut-être les
peintres l'europe il s'agit des singes
faut oui mais toi tu vas vite peut-être
que les gens ne vont pas aussi vite mais
ce qui m'est arrivé ce que j'ai vécu
tout à l'heure avec ma place j'en ai un
peu plus soft familiale et conviviale
allez dans un asile psychiatrique
de luxe voilà sonne à ma guise il ya de
fous qui s'amusent au bord d'une piscine
voilà donc ce qu'on est en train de
rigoler à un des deux fous qui tombent
dans l'eau voilà me sais pas nager
donc un lot de fou qui plonge il le
somme de la noyade il le sort de l'eau
et tout le lendemain il est convoqué
dans le bureau et le directeur le garde
lui dit écoutez félicitations hier vous
avez sauvé un de nos patients la noyade
malheureusement le soir même on l'a
retrouvé pendu dans sa chambre et liban
oui je n'accrochais pour qu'il sèche
[Applaudissements]
elle est très combat est très très
courte
maurice le même maurice tout à l'heure à
son pote d'avis j'en peux plus je n'en
peux plus ça fait 25 ans tous les matins
ma femme elle me demande 1000 euros
estime minoru shioiri ce qu'elle a fait
qui cet argent je sais pas moi je n'ai
jamais donné sahara se réveille à mener
fâche dans l'appartement et elle a la
tête dans le cul après un café pendant
le salon et voix et voit le et voile
gogh et gauguin est rayé ya marqué ça
elle va dans la cuisine il ya van gogh
paul gauguin et marquer sahara est là
dans son bureau il ya un renoir renoir
ayez bien remarqué sarah va dans liszt
david qu'est ce que tu appelles chez toi
et tes doigts le dos m qu'est ce que tu
as fait ta gueule j'ai un contrôle chez
tous mis à thonon
[Rires]
allez allez par l'aja n'est pas sale
elle semblait très court très poreuse et
après sa lettre maurice qui croise david
dans le sentier qui dit dix mois en
maurice j'ai appris par et ton magasin
il a brûlé l'eau tu fiches la semaine
prochaine c'est la prochaine
deux prostituées
oui qui se parlent familiale family
qu'est ce que tu as demandé 50 euros
comme les autres pas compris j'ai
compris pourquoi tes blagues ne marchait
pas je te jure
en fait c'est sur l'intonation de faim
de blague on croit qu'elle n'est pas
finie je prépare sans doute on va à
bercy c'est qu'elle est belle je mais
c'est pour le plaisir de l'accent c'est
un type qui qui qui se balade dans la
rue à bruxelles et qui y voit un type
romney deux chiens dont kiel la kossi
excusez moi monsieur de vous déranger là
deux marques à l'antenne la costière
lourdeur lui dit vous avez deux chiens
absolument magnifique du oui c'est vrai
dit ses deux chiens la super spéciale
aurait dit oui mais parce que eddy j'ai
toujours aimé c'est chasser c'est quelle
race a dit oui vous cher monsieur
celui-ci est un labrador ou telle autre
que oui l'autre aussi et il dit c'est ça
coûte cher à l'achat parce que ma femme
a toujours rêvé d'avoir des laboratoires
du saumon parlait pas si celui ci m'a
coûté une petite fortune
c'est l'autre fruits l'autre aussi ça
mange beaucoup dur alors ça ça dévore
celui ci me dévore dévore et dix
loteries oui l'autre au civil qui dit
cinéma pourquoi chaque fois que je vous
pose une question guide celui là est
l'autre aussi a dit excusez moi cher
monsieur c'est très sage parce que ce
chien là et à moi et dieu l'autre fait
oui notre site
[Applaudissements]
drôle et les blacks d'europe centrale
tu vois tu veux tu découvre un univers
laurent j'adore et là tout est en
préparation et y organise un car oui
c'est un homme très vieux très très
riches qui décide d'inviter trois mecs
chez lui voilà pour les faire qui fait
donc ils invitent un américain un
français et un rebeu chez lui voit la
danse on dansa dans sa villa et les
trois vont vont dans le jardin il ya une
grande piscine mais il ya un crocodile
dans la piscine parce que c'est un
blindé l'amf la des lions il a un
crocodile dans la piscine et tout est à
l'américain qui sautent qui voit pas il
se fait manger par le crocodile et à le
français qui sautent dans la piscine y
voit pas et où ils nagent en paix se
manger par le crocodile à leur but et ce
dans la piscine là le vieux riche
histoire comme ça à regarder leur bulle
est le crocodile comme celle du diable
sartec la cuisine l'acoss
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui cdc deux blondes qui sont dans la
forêt elle se promène et elles sont la
recherche dans sapins pour noël et donc
qu'elle marchait le marché de marche
comme ça et puis on a une qui creusait
toute la journée qu'on marche suis
fatigué fatigué bon c'est encore long
bah oui vous cherchez à sapin ou
cherchent à sapin vous avancez vous il
faut trouver un sapin c'est tout on n'a
pas le choix
allez voir d'accord d'accord mais bon le
prochain contre vous même s'il n'est pas
décoré où le prince a trouvé
[Applaudissements]
l'installation cette province trois
garçons qui sont perdus sur une île
déserte vont générer l'essor d'une
bouteille et à l'américain a français et
à beige et donc le bon génie de ce
qu'est ce que vous désirez plus au monde
l'américain dire j'aimerais beaucoup à
trouver mon métier mais à faire face et
à rentrer à new york les états up bon
génie hop et rock fera de famille ma
femme mes enfants
[Musique]
je propose jusqu'en face à un petit
tournoi pour faire une analyse pourquoi
et chez vous pourquoi ça ne marche pas
cad
moi je pense que pardon je peux je parle
j'ai je pense tout simplement que vous
n'êtes pas prêts à des choses qui sont
très humaine c'est 6 4 et futuriste
laurent nous a amenés sur un terrain
qu'on aime mais qu'on n'ose pas vraiment
c'est vrai j'en ai même pas prêt à temps
une proche voisine
la batterie au filet c'est pas un plus
comprendre mais par contre tu
n'accompagne pas tes chute par là c'est
la nation alors je ne sais pas pourtant
sur 16 ans ils n'ont jamais fait que je
t'ai dit au téléphone tu chantes en deux
minutes mais là ils vont rien avant pour
signaler alors vas-y fais nous fait nous
le pied de la prop abbas est sur le nom
après ces diffuseurs comme chantal asie
c'est un avion qui se crashe 400 morts
il ya trois survivants le pilote le
copilote et une hôtesse
alors in h jusqu'à jusqu'à l'arrivée il
il ya de l'eau il ya des poissons il ya
de quoi péché ils ont qu à faire du feu
et ils arrivent à survivre ils font des
signaux il n'ya pas d'avion qui passe ya
pas de bateau qui passait au bout de
trois mois
depuis lundi c'est bien beau mais quand
même fonctionnement fera peut-être qu'on
s'organise
vous proposez quoi l hôtesse d'yves moi
ça me dérange pas on peut faire un jour
toi et un jour toi et il marche comme ça
pendant un an et au bout d'un an
en ramassant des fruits l'hôtesse été
piquée par un serpent venimeux et le
moment elle meurt elle aimante
voilà et donc c'est très triste et tout
et puis au bout de trois mois le pilote
idéaux copilote bon voilà la vie
continue sexuellement qu'est ce que tu
proposes ben écoute on peut faire comme
on faisait avant on peut faire un coup à
toi un tournoi on alterne hockey en
qualif on s'attend au bout de six mois
et pilote idéaux copilote et vous de
vous je te parle j'en peux plus ça me
plaît pas ça me dégoûte
j'en peux plus et le copilote du jura
big tunes dis ça parce que c'est pas mon
truc non plus j'en peux plus ça me
dégoûte qu'est ce que tu proposes sediba
le mieux ce serait qu'on l'en terre
ça toujours à plano c'est un gars qui
croisent son pote dans la rue y croit
son pote et son pote et en sang il est
griffé de partout lui manque une dent il
les fera qu'à sa chemise et déchiré team
et frérot qu'est ce qui t'arrive c'est
quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe n'écoutons
on vient enterrer ma belle mère l'a dit
mais pourquoi si dans cet état elle
voulait pas alors moi les miennes c'est
différent chantal ya une moyens temps
avant ouais c'est ça l'esprit de j'ai
envie de combattre ce truc
chacun s'est dit d'accord alors vas-y
c'est la dernière chance alors on n'est
pas puni quand je t'ai pas téléphoné
pour orient tu te raconterai pour offrir
à boire deux axes en jeu d action ya
deux blackhawk arrivés d'une coupe et
c'est ce que j'ai dit à ma naissance
alors c'était à marseille et à personne
d'autre dans le wagon une personne est
persuadé tranquille il arrive à
marseille son âme il attend sur le quai
de la gare et lui dit ça va alors non je
ne sens pas la norme et non non non et
non
c'est vrai c'est mieux d'une seule
traite je suis le deuxième personnage
8 mars est allé s'asseoir ya personnel
très bien tout seul marseille à son ami
qu'est sur le quai qui le dit bonjour
bonjour bonjour et la ja zidane qui
sonne à la porte
maintenant fatigué dit oued et parce que
je n'étais pas bien d'un très mauvais
sens ah bon alors le mal à me martin
mode mais mais pourquoi tu avais qu à
changer de place
mais pourquoi tu avec un change de place
baillet personnes pour demander alors
j'ai pas changé
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Rires]
si vous voulez vous dire la scène un
truc j'ai vu là quelque chose de la
chance que la chute est tombé pas sur
l'autre personnage de quoi il a tu peux
pas 30 et le cours d'anglais alors c'est
ma fille qui me l'a dit au téléphone
toute alerte alors je suis pas si le
défi jusque sur le tour c'est un garçon
qui va prendre le relais regarde les
petites annonces d'un journal cours
d'anglais
enfin de 5 euros de l'heure c'est un peu
cher 35 c'est cher car il trouve pas
très beau bien seul coup une petite
annonce cours d'anglais cinq ans l'heure
il va hélas la maison et maladresses et
pis ils frappent à la porte
il frappe fort et lee c'est ici qu'ont
anglais à 5 euros
if his between
[Applaudissements]
merci ma fille pardon si tu la joues à
la fin et fif between là la limite kif
kif d'où tout est là il a raté refont
n'y a pas de vision entre alors cette
histoire préférée du rar darmon qui nous
raconte depuis trente ans et c'est
vraiment une histoire rapide et je pense
à coeur dans la bouche de chantal ça
fera un crayon ce qui n'a pas manqué
d'être et on peut saluer le talent que
jean da lois préparant une honte au lait
sont en jachère
sinon c'est une femme qui dit à son mari
tu pardon mais tu baises vraiment comme
un lapin il fait mais comment tu peux me
juger en 30 secondes histoire moi je
peux raconter d'histoires qui peut être
une histoire habib beye que j'adore ce
soir on les gère gérard darmon ccc une
des villas raconte très bien donc je
vais essayer de faire aussi bien que lui
ses deux copains qui se rencontrent irna
qui dit à l'autre tu vas bien le dif est
extrêmement bien elie dans deux mois je
suis milliardaire je faisais avant mais
pourquoi ben ali parce que j'ai inventé
un procédé révolutionnaire et euh là le
monde entier est en train de se
l'arracher
c'est à la fois écolo c'est fait c'est
vraiment de l'entreprise 2.0 salvia l'on
me dise et quoi il dit j'ai trouvé le
moyen de transformer la merde
amber seco qu'est ce que c'est que ces
conneries
même s'il est à 2 km je t'emmène vote
idi ben ouais je veux bien parce arrive
un truc sur cinq hectares on assez polis
un truc sublime je rentre du peintre
ighil bombe à la la la la première
machine pour passer de tu vas merde pas
dans un premier trio première
transformation la cli damman à 2km lama
tu vois c'est la deuxième transformation
ici elle conditionnement elle arrive de
vente une motte de beurre geste
incroyable a dit ferri dit ces bombes a
dit woods
donc il pourra boude pas je prends
il donne à son pote de poté oui ça quand
même un goût de merde hein ah bah oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la version agressive aussi à la fin un
peu plus vers la version dubitative
ouais ouais moi j'ai changé j'ai entendu
j'ai ardemment sortir une aussi louche
c'est monsieur et madame ça pullule ont
un fils comme ils s'appellent sa pub
ouais mais pas ahmed ahmed sa pub non
mais ça pue la m vous avez bien de
stocks non merci
une carrière ça c'est un mec un mec qui
est complètement fracasse qu'il a bu
fumé il a pris tout ce qui pouvait
prendre une déchirure il est en bas de
chez lui en compte un bot à lui dit tu
veux je te bouffer mon appart un parent
de fou il monte avec lui nous assène
l'entrée du salon
il rentre dans la chambre à coucher et
sa femme au lit avec un autre gars en
transférant ce chant - gauchy fasse ma
femme ça c'est moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'interprétation garder le jeu soit le
gaz
j'ai vécu moi j'en ai raconté beaucoup
de femmes il ya donc je me permets une
petite alesi khaled que c'est un une
femme c'est l'anniversaire de son mari
et son mari est fan de brigitte bardot
et donc pour son anniversaire a voulu
ramener brigitte bardot mais c'est
impossible alors possible de ramener
brigitte bardot anniversaire comme ça
donc pour lui faire plaisir a décidé
d'aller chez le tatoueur là un peu tard
a lâché le tatoueur lui j'aimerais bien
que vous me fassiez sur la fesse la tête
de brigitte bardot et à tous il ya
franchement fermés dans une heure le
temps de faire la tête de brigitte
bardot mais c'est impossible on n'aura
jamais le transfert à celle de brigitte
bardot en forme dans une heure et pas
bien le mec étoiles du bon bah écoutez
c'est pas grave faites-moi les initiés
les initiales témoins b sur chaque fai
soit guy hoquet buffet numéro b sur
chaque fesse le soir à rentrer chez elle
voit la voit son mari et tout a commencé
un peu à l'excité et où il commence à
faire l'amour et où il se passe comme ça
en levrette et/ou et son mari regarde
ses fesses comme c'est dit bob ceux qui
bossent
[Applaudissements]
la ministre évoque